Let's go.
All right.
All this feels good.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome all.
All right.
It's like Title Tuesday will be
beginning very shortly.
OK, Title Tuesday will start right now.
Welcome all.
OK, here's round one.
OK, guys, here we go.
Sorry, I started a little bit late.
I'm in stress city right now.
Let me know how you can how whether you
can hear me well.
Not too many expectations for today.
I'm just gonna try to play decently
Yeah, I've got a major headache, so
hopefully I get over 50 % Okay, cars not
playing Yeah, it's all theory Or CD ad
work see it.
I think before and then that's all I
know And Queen a5 is a move here This
is still theory um don't remember what
black's main move is here i think yeah
90s really not a move i think a5
supposed to go grab my water maybe
queen d2 i should have played in 95 he
can't play knight c5 i'll go bishop f3
the only issue is he might be able to
trade the darksford bishops which is
typically not wait favor.
Yeah the course is up for sale as you
guys already know Bortnik and I will be
holding a arena themed tournament after
at 7 30 p.m.
30 minutes after title Tuesday ends.
To sign up you need to join Bortnik's
club and then the join the signups will
open at 6 33 an hour before the
tournament starts.
The top finishers receive a course
it'll be really fun Bortnik and I will
be playing in it.
That'll be a nice little way to
reinvigorate some hype around the course.
I know that some people have asked for
refunds for some for completely
legitimate reasons in the last couple weeks.
I've been slow to give out refunds.
I will be doing that later today as well.
So if you're you know I'm you know if
you're listening and you requested a
refund for no reason then I will still
be giving you that refund but just
please be patient.
I mean we've gotten a couple we
expected that but I'm again.
I'm not trying to scam anybody.
I just have been ridiculously busy The
horse will be on sale for 24 hours
Okay, let's focus on the games It's in
the link the club sign up is in the
link So just exclaim course tournament
and then follow the link to the club
sign up and then the tournament sign up
link will Open an hour before the
tournament starts Yeah, we're just
making moves here Okay, what's the link
is wrong?
I'll update it after this game.
I gotta kill it.
Thank you.
Yeah, so I have a raging headache today.
I'm like trying to do 400 things before
I leave for Oslo tomorrow.
I'm very stressful.
So we're just gonna chill.
Chess Kid Cup is happening in Oslo.
So you guys you know the CCC
tournaments have you ever seen the with
Tanya and Hest from that studio you
know what I'm talking about?
There have been like two of them so far
so this next one the finals I'll be
commentating with Canty, Owl, and Tanya.
I know Constitution Day but I'm flying
in on the morning of the 18th I'm
leaving New Jersey tomorrow at 6 p.m.
but by the time my flight gets in it'll
be this it'll be the 18th.
I don't like my time pressure but if he
brings himself down to two seconds
he'll lose on time okay i mean i don't
know what he's doing you can't just get
you can't get yourself to one second in
five moves okay rodstein no idea what
polar on morad means coal means
everything i think I definitely can't
get first, but I can get top 5.
I mean Arabic and Hebrew are a lot of
words similar.
I think Malik means king.
That's all I know.
Hebrew is closest to Arabic, yeah.
Very close.
Not very close, but a lot of similar
words, I think.
Manek, yeah.
It's also first name.
Malik Monk is King Monk.
That's actually funny.
King, King Monk.
Scrubs are more than welcome.
Ten bucks from Raiden Ranch.
Thank you.
It has to be winning,
but I never know how to actually finish
these games, ever.
I never know how to finish this.
I've been thinking and then I see a
move that's tempting and it doesn't
work and I keep getting stuck on it.
It's a page 6.
It plunders to knight g4.
H3 is definitely a bad move, but I
don't see anything else.
Ghost G4, wow.
I was not expecting that.
I was expecting G3.
I guess he wants Rook G3?
It requires, it's not unrated, and yes,
the theme tournament requires you to
play the Jabal, that's kind of the point.
And it's unrated.
Obviously, because the theme
tournaments can't be rated because you
have to play a certain opening.
Yeah, I'm starting to Still, black is
better for sure, but now he has this.
I always get outplayed in title two.
Always.
I don't get it, I just can't find moves
in them.
I should still be okay, I mean this
should not be worse for black.
X takes queen takes d6, I think is good
for black on knight d6.
There's knight h3, I have to go here.
d2.
What do I have here?
Nothing, okay.
g5 maybe?
Report the knight.
I mean without increment again the game
is over.
Every game I would be over without increment.
Literally the game is over without increment.
Okay, I like the look of knight d3.
I don't know if it works tactically,
but I'll try Yeah, I don't trap his
Queen actually sadly I Have nothing
this is domination on all fronts, but I
have no actual move And now he goes 95
and wins I was I wonder how is this
possible I Can try to sack no nothing works.
I mean I have to try to sack my Queen
00:12:43,770 --> 00:12:43,650
Only chance.
I don't understand this.
This is some kind of curse and it's
like, it's like I'm cursed at some
games trying to create complications here.
Get them to flag.
No.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Only way that I can win these games is
by flagging.
I don't know what it is I need to work on.
It's like I just, I can't find me.
Maybe I wasn't that much better to
begin and maybe my mistake was assuming
I was winning?
Yeah, it's equal actually.
I mis-evaluated this.
I was looking for a win and I should
just play chess.
I am better after knight a4.
Yeah, here I'm already worse.
I just, I mean you can't really blame
me for assuming that this position is winning.
It looks so dominant for black.
I have like ideal pieces, but I just
don't have a clear way to break through.
It's weird.
But somehow I hesitate lot more than I
would in normal games because I know in
normal games I can flag him even if he
refutes my line.
That's honestly the root of the problem.
Root of the problem is that in a three
plus zero game I would un-Bortnik one again.
Very nice.
I would just play something and my
opponent would think until they've got
20 seconds and the game would be over
because I would just flag them easily.
Fabby just hung Maiden one of Bortnik.
Oh he beat Fabby.
Oh my gosh.
Oh he did hang Maiden one.
Okay he was much worse.
Now that's misleading.
He was getting outplayed.
Wow, Gordnik beat Fabian in the Javava
London, awesome.
Okay, so pretty good score actually, 7
out of 9 is very respectable, but it's
not going to win the tournament.
It is a draw, this is a draw with best
play, Knight versus Rook is a draw.
That's good to know.
It's actually quite an easy draw.
Playing Kramnik, okay.
Yeah, I've waited for this a long time.
Okay, let's actually try to give him a
good game.
For some revenge is a sozin b3 I don't
remember this line I mean this is not a
theoretical line at all he's playing
playing some random silly line and I'm
uncomfortable for black actually trying
to stop g5 which is very big why did I
The problem is, in 9p7 he can sac on
his queen,
which is a beast.
Okay, I'll take the plunge, I'll allow
bishop e6.
Otherwise, otherwise I just can't get
my pieces.
I'll put my queen on this, though, and
as is standard in knight art positions.
But it's a good move.
Really good move.
I missed.
Now 9-8-4, I mean his discretion.
Not a fun position.
But I do have some counter play in Vegas.
It was very positional.
Yeah, I have to castle and try that I
made a miss If I don't like you five,
okay Let's go.
All right All this feels good Yeah,
that's frickin right anything to say
increment Andes Mr..
And mrs..
Mr..
I can't play with increment Mr..
And mrs..
I can't play with increment or silent
for once Okay, let's win the last one
or at least trying that was a nice one
Yeah, Queen h4 is really beautiful.
This is just a sexy move.
I also had rook d5 now notice I mean
obviously here you should have take I
mean he had some more practical chances
he blundered rook d4 takes a4 but nice
yeah there were some nice tactics there
if I win the last one I get I get into
the top five I have no chances to win
the tournament but I do have a nice
chance to win to get into top five okay
when I said revenge when I said revenge
I meant for a classical game we played
a classical game in twenty okay we're
playing a three Zaga these obviously
beatable I don't know I play the
elephant maybe I should play night f3
or Salimo yeah this line I know pretty
well actually Jones played against okay
so it clearly choice I go looked it up
unfortunately we're supposed to go a6
and then d4 maybe you didn't look at
him he's just bluffing wait it looks
like I might be winning here if I'm
careful I have knight b5 as a candidate
move let's not take too long chocolate
c4 yeah I know before it doesn't work
okay um might be fine then with knight
a5 I have knight a7 If we need I'm
trying to find a move against Queen e7.
I have some promising lines there, but
I don't see He's using up a lot of
clock here.
I don't see a move for him Simply don't
see him.
He might have to move his nobody even
if he moves his knight It's bad.
He might have to play 95, but I don't
see what he does after a night a son
Okay, we need something played so I
have c4 96 then he gives up his Queen
and it's not it's obviously not winning
And there's 90 to end the game I don't
give a damn.
I'm gonna play it.
I don't give a shit Rest myself right
night a3 was also possible the good
thing about this moves.
I have two directions I can go in I'm
gonna keep the pressure going on his
clock Okay, what if I go here I Should
have gone to e4.
I should have gone ID for Because that
was sloppy.
I was very sloppy right there very
sloppy I'm just gonna keep playing
fast, no worries, I'm still winning.
Still winning.
I think I'm still winning at least.
And the Torizaga is unbelievably tricky
though, so let's just continue playing
like I don't give a damn.
The freaking world.
Oh, he has this move!
I don't care.
Go out, go out, here and mate him.
B4 is in my pocket?
It takes takes bishop d6, where is the
win here?
There is a win, I'm sure.
Where is it?
I'm getting nervous here.
Hmm, a seven doesn't work.
How is this not just all over on the spot?
Look at this position.
C4, no.
If D6, he moves his king to D7, I mean.
Okay.
Just don't see it.
I guess I can go here.
I can think a little bit longer.
I mean, he has to think here.
I don't see a move for him again, but
I'm sure he has one and he's gonna find
it so we have to be precise here Okay,
rebuilding the time advantage here rook d8.
I have rook d5 And he doesn't see a
move either.
He goes queen d7, which I saw Can't I
take Queen e6, he might probably play.
I have to watch the back rank mate
Obviously I screwed this up, but I'm
still completely winning.
d4 maybe I mean, b4 is a little bit iffy.
What if I go like that?
No, shit.
So then he's gonna knight.
Ah, but then I have a bishop c5.
It's so confusing.
How does he even figure out how to move here?
No.
That was not the way.
Ah, where is it?
Oh my gosh.
Did I blunder?
I did, didn't I?
Where's the freaking win?
Where is the win?
I can...
I mean I can play it simp- no shit!
What do I do here?
Don't panic, don't panic, it's fine.
Here.
Alright.
Nope, check, there we go.
There we go!
I didn't panic, I just sat there until
I found the win.
Let's go!
And that's why I built up that time
advantage so I could do this!
Come on Sasha, come on Sasha, you got this.
If Sasha wins this game, he wins the tournament.
I had a lot of wins, but listen,
listen, listen, when you, when you're
sitting there and your time is ticking
and you know, it's a lot is on the line.
It's harder than it seems.
It's so easy to screw this position up.
Let's go Sasha.
You got this.
He's going to win.
Sasha's going to win this.
He's going to win title Tuesday.
Oh my God.
This would be awesome.
Come on, come on.
Couple more moves, couple more moves,
96 and it's over.
He's got it.
Bortnik's got it, 96, 96, come on.
No, yes, he's got it.
Bortnik wins, title Tuesday.
Clear first with 10 out of 11.
And I've got terrible tie breaks with
nine out of 11.
I'm gonna tie for second, no, tie for
third, ugh.
But I passed Karawana and stuff.
Yeah, amazing stuff for, ooh, this
might be a draw too.
Why is he going for it?
Yeah, 10 out of 11 is unbelievable.
Oh, this frickin' Andraken's gonna win.
The guy had like 15 draws.
Okay, Andraken passes me as well
because he has better tie breaks.
But still, I'm very happy with the end
of the tournament.
Given my, like, condition right now, I
won the last five.
I'll take it.
Everyone's happy.
Yeah, Bordnik wins clear first.
So I mean, I've got a pretty bad
headache and I'm just tired in general.
I should not have blundered the second game.
I mean, I should I should be a
billionaire and have seven wives, like
a lot of things should be the case.
Yeah, I think 11 out of 11 has happened.
Browser.
Okay, the arena happens in 24 minutes.
So folks, sign up for the arena.
Okay, I got fifth.
I actually get a prize.
Not bad.
I actually have pretty good tie breaks.
I mean, I could have gotten third if I didn't.
If I'm drinking a drawn, I would have
gotten fourth, but no, this is really good.
This is a really good performance.
We both made the top five.
Bordnik wins.
And I beat Kramnik, it's always good.
The prize money is like $50 which is
crazy because it's that friggin title
Tuesday Yeah, I was getting crushed by
Kramnick and then and then suddenly
things turn around He just let me let
me finish my development and once I
started getting the dark squares The
best thing about this game is that I
actually outplayed him positionally
which always feels good Because I'm you
know the whole the whole the whole I'm
just tactics narrative is not always
the case like I can actually play some
good positional moves from time to time
Here I was playing almost perfectly I think,
but yeah I'm proud of Bordnik, that's awesome.
First place is $1,000.
He finally got a good pairing in the
last round.
Usually Sasha gets screwed over with pairings.
Usually Bordnik gets really screwed
with pairings, but in the last round he
got a really really good pairing.
Well what do you mean by that?
I mean $1,000 for first is okay, it's
an online tournament, that happens
every week.
It would be nice if what I would prefer
is that the prizes were more evenly
spread out and that there'd be maybe
like at least a hundred bucks for the
first top five finishers.
Yeah, I mean, a thousand bucks given
how stacked the tournament is is a
joke, but still, I mean, at least it
gives people a chance to support their
income online.
You got to be reasonable.